it seems that most victories come with a
price that's no different in the world
of anime for every major victory or
reason to celebrate behind it is usually
a painful decision that a character has
had to make when you think about it it's
the sacrifice and the journey that makes
seeing light at the end of the tunnel
all the more sweeter right on that note
today we're looking at some of the most
emotional sacrifices in anime
[Music]
[Applause]
starting off the list is elaine
sacrificed from the seven deadly sins at
tenth place
ban and elaine didn't start out as best
friends the bandits spent a good chunk
of his past seeking the fountain of
youth only to keep getting thwarted by
the fountain's guardian elaine the two
soon develop feelings for each other
though alas happy moments have to win
don't they a demon attacks the forest
and wounds both ban and elaine and
instead of taking water from the
fountain for herself elaine makes band
drink it granting him the immortality
that he sought this flashback would
surely linger in the hearts of people
who watched the seven deadly sins for a
long long time
[Music]
foreign
jonathan joestar's death from jojo's
bizarre adventure is at number nine on
the list
having believed that he'd put an end to
his nemesis dio jonathan joestar spends
his last moments in phantom blood a
happy and married man that happiness
doesn't last long though as he gets
attacked once more by a still alive deo
during his honeymoon using the last of
his strength he traps deo and allows his
family to escape as he succumbs to his
wounds jonathan goes out with a smile
having saved his family and forgiving
his worst enemy jonathan's legacy
carries on for the series but even if
the series were to end at this point
he'd already be remembered as an
honorable man who paid the ultimate
price for the rest of the joestar family
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
for our seventh moment we have vegeta
blowing himself up in an attempt to take
down majin buu at the time of his
introduction vegeta was shown to be
ruthless and uncaring he didn't give a
damn about anything but strength all in
all you can see why his eventual
decision to sacrifice himself in the
busag is one of the most gripping
moments of that arc despite not caring
about bulma and trunks it's obvious that
the prince of saiyans is lying and that
he's already completed the character
development that prompts him to
sacrifice himself for the world vegeta
realizes the consequences of all his
previous actions and decides to blow
himself up going down in a literal blaze
of glory he makes the choice of dying
for the world in an act of personal
redemption
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
at number six it's rider's doom battle
against gilgamesh from fate zero if
there's a list of all-time fake anime
moments rider's battle against gilgamesh
would surely make him this fight has it
all glorious noble fantasms heartwarming
farewell speeches and gilgamesh finally
finding a worthy opponent most of all it
showcases the fire of determination
burning within ryder's soul in one
climactic battle even while finding
himself completely outmatched against
the king of heroes ryder charges on
taking everything that the gate of
babylon can toss at him his sheer will
pushes him on but he was finally put
down for good
yuri
at the fifth spot we have a sacrificing
his life for luffy being a storyline
revolving around saving luffy's brother
part of the climax of the marine foot
arc ends with a cloud of despair looming
over our heroes akainu gets the upper
hand on ace and moves to finish off
luffy it's then the ace steps in and
takes the blow for his brother one that
would ultimately kill him instead of
possibly living on full of regret ace
makes the decision to die in an act of
protecting luffy he doesn't die in a
lost battle against someone out of his
own league but on his own terms it could
feel unfair especially to one piece fans
but ace's death has a legacy in it that
it finally convinces luffy that he has
to keep getting stronger
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
irwin smith's sacrifice against the
beast titan ranks fourth on the list
while the commander of the survey corps
did care for his men he's ruthless and
wouldn't hesitate in sacrificing them
for the betterment of mankind needless
to say the command is someone who's
caused the deaths of hundreds of people
soon though he reflects on his actions
and realizes that he's been a hypocrite
all along he's unwilling to die for the
greater cause while preaching that
ideology to justify his orders and the
inner desire that's fueled by a moment
with his father it's this realization
that drives him to lead the charge
against the beast titan this distraction
gives levi the opening needed to
confront and defeat zeke and in the end
it's irwin's desire to die with the
fallen recruits that pushes levi to save
the lethally wounded armin instead
leaving him to die after a moment of
redemption
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in the battle against pain
during his infiltration mission jiraiya
finds himself in the battle against
konam it turns out that he has his work
cut out not only does he have to contend
with konan he has to fight for his life
against pain or what's supposed to be
pain if then that he finds out that pain
is actually an entity composed of
multiple bodies armed with unique powers
despite his valiant efforts jariah finds
himself overwhelmed by the pains there's
hope at the end of the master ninja's
life he dies not with sadness or regrets
but with a smile
knowing that he's done his part in his
last moments he entrusts the world to
the pupil who he knows would soon carve
his spot in history as the savior of the
world
[Music]
sacrifice at the end of code geass takes
the second spot on the list
still held as one of the most iconic
endings to a legendary series it would
be hard to top lelouch's sacrifice at
the end of code gyas taking in the
hatred of the world and directing it
towards him as an all-powerful demagogue
lelouch finishes his longtime plan with
suzaku by having suzaku take the guys of
zero and kill him truly a gutsy plan at
the cost of the greatest sacrifice given
everything else has happened would
anything less have sufficed with the one
focus of hatred gone lelouch cements
himself as a messianic archetype one who
has paid the ultimate price to save the
world
[Music]
is
the number one sacrifice in anime
belongs to isaac naterro one of the most
defining and my personal favorite battle
in chimera ant arc is the one between
kimera and king marum and isaac notaro
chairman of the hunter association it's
a battle of two very powerful characters
at peak performance despite his withered
state and vulnerability after being
overpowered natero manages to strike
fear in meruem's heart claiming the
latter knows nothing about humanity's
endless potential for evolution and
malice nutero then pierces his own heart
with a finger and detonates the bomb in
a last attempt to put an end to
marowan's reign of terror for natero
that death is a satisfying one his long
search for a worthy opponent has finally
ended and he was able to pass away in
peace
[Music]
so what do you think then guys if you
have any suggestions on some moments
that we've missed do not hesitate to let
your voices be heard i'll see you next
time on vinicius
[Music]
yes
[Music]